[Music]
200 years as a republic
on wednesday pedu commemorates a
landmark anniversary
the independence from the spanish
colonialists
now for the first time a farmer and
rural primary school teacher
takes over the presidency pedro castillo
comes from one of the poorest districts
of peru
many peruvians say they feel represented
but jessica laguna says her community
on the outskirts of the capital lima has
little to celebrate
the republic is 200 years old but
there's inequality everywhere
we're rolling in the same mud and we
can't escape
we wish our children could have it
better but we always have needs and
there's no work
we wish for change but we can't do
better
they claim the state has forgotten the
poor members of this community build the
roads themselves
they raise animals and eat together in a
communal kitchen
many families here at the alto rita mal
community
live on less than eight dollars a day
millions like them
have come from remote places for decades
people have been migrating from the
andes to the capitol
looking for a better life and they ended
up living in shanty towns
where they continued to live in poverty
margarita algawa says she doesn't have
any hope that the new president will
bring
change
my grandparents my parents we've always
been poor i was brought here as a child
to escape poverty and look
we the poor will always be poor no one
remembers us
president pedro castillo has promised
that there will not be any more poor in
a rich country
but analysts say the road for him will
be uphill
and tough in 200 years we have learned
to survive
rather than to live our hardships are
severe
we have gone from being one of the
countries with the highest level of
development
to where we are now at the end of the
scale
from being almost unknown pedro castillo
rose to the presidency
offering change for millions of poor
peruvians
and while many hope he delivers on his
promises
many are wary that he will mariana
sanchez lima peru